there's new technology that aims to stop  drunk driving  before it begins after more than 10  years and a hundred million dollars the  driver alcohol detection system for  safety  is finally a reality it's a sensor in  your car it can detect blood alcohol  content on your breath  in a matter of seconds and if it's above  the legal limit your car won't start  this technology actually provides us  that extra benefit  of knowing our driver is going to be  safe with no alcohol in their system  not started very interesting this  technology is going to be made available  in the fall  and could turn up in cars and trucks  soon afterwards